out there and he spelled it out he's not
hiding it he's out there wrecking up
Miley that's what he said and that's
what I'd like to know how does he feel
the guy said if the guy's leaving the
high body count and you haven't let him
answer yet and I'd like him to answer
how do I feel I think um it comes down
to listen the girl wants to back up
numbers that's up to her it's her body
her choice I don't I don't give up no
I'm not talking about if a woman I'm
talking about you said that eventually
you'd like to settle down I'm talking
about what is the highest body count
that you would accept for your future uh
partner don't ask the question no no
question I don't care answer numbers are
subjective so if someone could think 10
is high someone could think of 100 times
because it's all subjective but I
depends on the person listen I would
like a number a number what do you want
I would like single digits single digits
single digits okay so can I have you
ever I know that not a lot of people
talk about body count I'll talk about
the women that you associate with yeah
have you spoken to them about body count
uh it crops Up Normally it crops up
they're masking me I'll reverse the
question on them have any of them been
double digits all of them have been
double digits okay actually no no not
all of them no no it's given some of
their Jews some of them have been oh
you've been the double digit number 10.
I've put them over the edge yeah yeah
but uh no most I I never actively ask a
girl oh how how many guys you slept with
whatever I've never ever asked that
question however some goals will go to
me oh I bet you slept with loads of
girls and I'm like I just I don't ever
answer the question and then I'll go
well how many boys use that with no tell
me and they're asking me how many I've
said I've just gone you so when you
decide to settle down yeah will you ask
her what happened but it'll be that
question will be somehow incorporated
into a load of questions in the stage of
talking it won't be something I asked
six months in oh that will def that that
will be a building block to me depending
where I go further this person yeah so
it does matter to you then of course of
course it matters you said single digits
of course of course nine is the time
listen if you said to me right now you
said if you said to me me and you just
meet at a bar and with no flirtation
between us we're just talking you said
to me randomly a conversation come up
you said I'll set with 50 guys I would
not judge you one bit
no but let's not bro
I've just met the guy no no no no so I'm
just asking you but she's made she met
with 50 bodies yeah it's no way that but
just honestly like it's not singing
religious bro of course he said he
wouldn't Because unless they're on the
flip side let's say on the flip side
it's been four months you've been seeing
some girls she's really nice she's
attract I wouldn't let it get four
months
okay let's say three months you've been
seeing her she's attract active your
family love her she's beautiful loads of
guys think yo have you got this girl and
then you ask her how many bodies have
you catch and she says double digits are
you gonna no sorry I'm just gonna I
don't believe you words
my mom loves you how old is she she's
30.80
let's just put it in that perspective
it's been three months you've been
seeing this girl she's beautiful your
friends think yo how have you got this
girl she's absolutely stunning she's
career driven she's ambitious she's
everything that you value in a girl but
then she likes to say do you know what
yo like I've it's double digits I've
slept with 20 people are you then gonna
say
don't do it
or play a part are you then gonna say to
her you could be the love of my life but
sorry you've slept with 20 men let me
know explain are you gonna do that oh
there's a great scenario it's a great
scenario I respect what you're saying
but Joseph would not let it get to three
months for asking that question and the
love of my life could never say anything
if he was listening to what you said he
actually said that that would be part of
his vetting process yeah so I suppose
that you go for that before I wouldn't
say it again so although you said you
don't judge women but you do he's not
judging
that's fine that's fine but just but
China you didn't say that but he said oh
I wouldn't judge you he does wouldn't
charge you as a person I judge you as
being my partner for the rest of my life
I think the problem is this what
happened last time right
um and this is what I think I was
getting a bit of backlash on social
media from a few people but it's like
men having a standard is not judging you
so you can do whatever you want you can
win so let me just reiterate you right
this is what I believe I believe a woman
has the right to wear what she wants Uma
has the right to go where she wants she
can sleep with who she wants
consensually a woman has a autonomy a
sovereignty over her body but along with
those rights a man has rats too and I
have rights that I don't have to accept
a woman that's taking that and this is
where the people start to get upset oh
but but but because I personally don't
want to take a woman that believes
sleeping with 20 men is good for her
like I I look at her
um I look at her how she makes decisions
her decision making and I don't
personally think that's that's something
that that I want and when you say that
that's when you people get mad and the
reason people get mad is because you've
been told you can go out and do whatever
you want and sleep whatever you want and
be with everyone of course you can but
it doesn't mean that you have access to
whoever you want and that's why people
get upset so by him saying that oh yeah
um she can sleep with 50 man that's fine
but I don't want her that's a preference
he's not he's not judging her no if he
says that's the perfect example because
bucks they were so quick to jump on him
yeah but but what they didn't realize is
that he's out there racking up mileage
right bodies mileage whatever you want
to call it and the women don't care he
don't care because it's mutual yeah but
when he comes to want to wive someone
and he don't want it it's a problem to
the women you're saying I'm polluting
the environment
the people allowing you to pollute your
environment whoa go for it because I'm
concerned I have no problem with you
like she said girls don't care I have no
problem with you doing whatever you want
to do because like you said you're being
honest about it I also have no problem
with you deciding that when you come to
settle down that you want somebody with
a low body count what I have a problem
with is all the modern women out there
that are sleeping with men like you and
then can't accept that men like you want
a woman with a low body count Auntie
that's what I always say like you look
perfect you know your buff your tanned
you're young you're handsome you're
driven and any woman will have you but
what they don't understand is that you
don't want any woman facts you want a
woman for today you don't want a woman
for forever and you're gonna get lots of
women for today and they will wonder why
don't they want me forever because
you've got a high body count
because this is where you are yeah
because I don't suppose that when you
decide to get your partner would you
feel great about her going out in skimpy
clothes and drinking tequila and dancing
on tables you have a problem with that
listen listen this is my view I said
this earlier I do listen if I trust her
and she trusts me there's a mutual trust
between us
I do not if she's going to cheat she's
going to cheat
let me say this is on the table with her
friends and there's another giza's table
I don't care yeah why does it care
I don't care where you go I don't care
who you're with as long as you're not
nothing like
yeah
I want to know
Jesus that is disrespectful in my life
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible